big news guys now that the Republicans
are poised to retake the house very
likely the Senate and probably many
Governors Mansions the liberals who have
tormented us over the past two years who
shut down our businesses who made our
relatives die alone who kept our kids
out of school who forced us to choose
between keeping our jobs and injecting
ourselves with a dangerous experimental
drug the liberals who called us idiots
and murderers for not wanting to destroy
the global economy and turn our kids
into Lab Rats those Liberals are now
calling for a truce
what are the odds that isn't that so
weird headline in the Atlantic let's
declare a pandemic amnesty we need to
forgive one another for what we did and
said when we were in the dark about
covet you know we just all we just all
did some things you know some of us
um kept our kids out of school and
forced your relatives to die alone and
some of us
had our kids kept out of school and had
our relatives forced you know it's just
like it's just like we're all kind of
the same here right some of us destroyed
the global economy and injected everyone
forcefully with an experimental and
Dangerous Drug and some of us had that
done to us and so it's like kind of all
the same right and we all just need to
move past it don't we
I I won't read the entire article you
should just some highlights
while discussing the social distancing
and the stupid hankies on your face and
all that they say these these
precautions were totally misguided
in April 2020 no one got the coronavirus
from passing someone else hiking outdoor
transmission was vanishingly rare our
cloth masks made out of old bandanas
wouldn't have done anything anyway but
the thing is
we didn't know
we didn't know some of us knew I knew
that you knew but no we just we didn't
know some people thought that the hanky
was going to stop the global pandemic
you know we just didn't know
in spring and summer 2020 we had only
glimmers of information reasonable
people people who cared about children
and teachers advocated on both sides of
the reopening debate they didn't
they didn't all the people who were
completely wrong and who often had very
bad intentions were on the side of
keeping the schools closed and all the
people who had mostly good intentions
and who were correct were on the side of
reopening the schools
the people who got it right for whatever
reason may want to gloat those who got
it wrong for whatever reason may feel
defensive and retrench into a position
that doesn't Accord with the facts
treating pandemic choices as a scorecard
on which some people racked up more
points than others is preventing us from
moving forward
no no you you are preventing us from
moving forward you you people you Libs
who got everything wrong and who
inflicted a great deal of pain usually
intentionally usually with a lot of Glee
on people
You by refusing to acknowledge your
transgressions uniquely your
transgressions you are preventing us
from moving on because you won't let us
learn a damn thing from the last two
years you won't acknowledge anything you
want to admit anything you won't say
that you're sorry
we have to put these fights aside and
declare a pandemic amnesty
moving on is crucial now because the
pandemic created many problems that we
still need to solve yeah right the first
problem we need to solve is you people
you're the problem
you're the one who inflicted all the
problems on us there's a pandemic such
as it is the virus was just a virus We
There are viruses there are epidemics
there are pandemics that that was not
the trauma of the last two and a half
three years
the policies that you all forced on us
the hideous
anti-human policies global economy
Global political order destroying
policies that you inflicted on us that
was the problem pretty big change of
tune wouldn't you say
because last year you didn't get all
this Kumbaya uh let's all get along kind
of stuff last year they were laughing at
the thought of our deaths LA Times
mocking anti-vaxxers covid deaths is
ghoulish yes but it may be necessary
it's necessary to mock the deaths of
conservatives who are skeptical of the
dominant regime they were making the
moral case for mocking our prospective
deaths
but that was then
you see and this is now
that was back then when they had all of
the power but now we conservatives might
have even a little tiny bit of power so
let's just call it a day and move on
right right
I don't think so I think the best that I
can offer in response to let's have a
pandemic amnesty is military tribunals I
want these monsters arrested and tried
and shipped off to Guantanamo Bay
frankly that's my initial negotiating
position and it damn well had better be
the position of the Republicans that
we're about to elect because anything
less than a full accounting of the lies
and deceit and outright Crimes of the
covid era will be nothing more than an
invitation for the libs to do it all
again I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Abraham
Cardenas who says it's very nice of
Michael to dress up as Rachel Maddow and
to have a picture of Joe Biden on his
desk yes that street was very spooky
when I had that bust of Joe Biden there
that skeletal bust and yesterday of
course it was mad out Monday leads right
into Noel's member baby and so I think a
great way to kick it off I've lost my
lesbian glasses for today I'm back as my
own man here ready to say true things to
protect my country to protect my wealth
and yours which is why you got to check
out Birch gold right now text Knowles to
98 98 98 inflation continues to plague
our economy the current administration's
irresponsible spending patterns continue
to exacerbate the problem now is not the
time to have all your money tied up in
the stock market do not let your savings
wither away hedge against inflation with
gold from Birch gold text Knowles kwles
to 98 98 98 Birch gold will send you a
free info kit on protecting your savings
with gold Birch gold is giving out a
free gold bar with any Purchase made by
December 22nd this offer must be claimed
by Black Friday with almost 20 years of
experience in converting IRAs and 401ks
into precious metals IRAs Birch gold can
help you too do not sit around while the
fed devalues your hard-earned money text
Knowles kwles to 98 98 98 and learn how
you can convert at least part of your
savings into a precious metals Ira if
you place an order by December 22nd
Birch gold will send you a free gold bar
text Knowles kwles to 98 9898 it has
been a rough few years hasn't it hasn't
it but this year
seems like things are kind of turning
around
I'm not I am not totally depressed and
despairing and black Builder okay I
think this year's actually been pretty
good one we're almost certainly about to
elect a ton of Republicans
hopefully get some accountability for
the last few years hopefully move the
country in a good direction but but just
the Supreme Court would be enough to say
that 2022 is one of the greatest years
in American history despite Joe Biden
despite the potential of World War III
despite the record high inflation
despite all of that
just the Supreme Court let's not forget
2022
is the year that we overruled Roe v Wade
and Planned Parenthood V Casey and
there's an analysis that just came out
from 538 which is the sort of Center
left
polling Outlet
538 by Nate silver
has new data uh which which indicate
that at least 10 000 women were unable
to get an abortion in July and August
because of the Dobbs decision
now of course 538 because it's left wing
is presenting this as a terrible awful
thing oh no 10 000 women were denied
that medical care and the Reproductive
Rights and isn't this terrible and that
was just in two months imagine later on
when even more of these pro-life laws
are implemented
I look at that number and I think
oh my goodness this is this is some of
the greatest news in American history
because you're finally seeing 850 000
people a year are killed through
abortion or were during the reign of of
Roe and Casey
and now that's turning around ten
thousand we it's very difficult for
human beings to conceive of numbers
greater than a hundred
but ten thousand people
is a lot of people
it's a lot of people my my graduating
high school class was about 300 330
people
so that's
three times my high school class
is a thousand people
10 times so 30 times my high school
class is 10
thousand people 30 times my graduating
high school class
that number of people will be alive
because five justices on the Supreme
Court had courage
we think of these these Court decisions
and these laws in very abstract terms
what they mean for society or Humanity
or the culture or whatever
we're talking about individual people
how many friends do you have
like five maybe people don't have a ton
of close friends
think about how how valuable every
single one of those people is to you
what you wouldn't give to make sure that
that person gets to live gets to be if
they were in danger if they were in
danger of death to be rescued
now multiply that person by ten thousand
there will be in 10 years from now 15
years from now people will be doing
interviews
maybe 20 years from now they'll be doing
interviews saying my I am alive today
because Amy Barrett and Brett Kavanaugh
and Neil Gorsuch and
Sam Alito and Clarence Thomas had
courage and moral Clarity that's
incredible news
now there's even
if not I'm not going to say better news
but there's more great news coming down
the pike from the Supreme Court the hits
seem poised to keep on coming
because now this term the Supreme Court
is going to take on another major social
question that conservatives have fought
in vain for for many decades and that
even conservative appointments and the
court people like Sandra Day O'Connor
and other people have kind of squished
on and so our hopes have been dashed on
this before The Supreme Court is going
to take up the question of racial
discrimination in college admissions
better known as affirmative action
with the idea that certain students will
not get into college because of their
race and other students will have an
unfair advantage in getting into college
because of their race there's really
really good news on this front the
Supreme Court just heard oral arguments
in two cases taking on affirmative
action in college yesterday and the
signs are very very promising
so the Supreme Court hears the the
oral arguments yesterday in these two
cases about affirmative action in
college being brought by a legal group
that is challenging this on behalf of
Asian students you know Asian students
and white students are put at a
disadvantage and black students and
Hispanic students get an advantage now
we have a conservative court it's at
least a 5-4 conservative court because
Roberts is uh squish who will usually
side with the Liberals on really
contentious issues but you've still got
then five four you know you can at least
kind of count on the conservative court
and then there's even better news
because the newest just Justice uh
katanji Jackson the Justice who doesn't
know what a woman is she's had to recuse
herself from these cases because one of
the cases involves Harvard and she was
just recently on one of the boards at
Harvard and so it's a conflict of
interest so she's out so the deck is
even more in the the Stacked in the
direction of the conservatives
there there was an amazing uh
poll that was done uh Paul Pew research
pulled Americans and said should race
and ethnicity be a factor in admissions
75 three quarters of Americans say no
absolutely not
and don't forget the Supreme Court
watches the polls the Supreme Court
reads the newspapers
so the the fact that public opinion is
now with the conservatives and with
Justice when we're talking about
affirmative action this is a really
really good sign
so the cases are students for fair
admissions versus Harvard and students
for fair admissions versus the
University of North Carolina
the most telling part of the oral
arguments yesterday was when
Clarence Thomas the OG the Mack Daddy on
the court Mr Conservative oldest
conservative member there was was
grilling the lawyer for UNC about
diversity
because the libs say we need affirmative
action because we need diversity because
diversity is really good for education
and so it's in the interest of the
university to have
diversity by which they mean giving
extra points to black students and
taking points away from Asians and
whites
and Clarence Thomas
black man on the court can't it's very
difficult to call the guy racist he says
okay judge I'm following your line of
argument
now what is your or um okay Council okay
lawyer for UNC I'm following your line
of argument
now what is the evidence that diversity
is good for for education
here's the question
uh Mr Park
um I've heard the word uh diversity
quite a few times and I don't have a
clue what it means
uh it seems to mean everything for
everyone
uh the and I'd like you first you did
give some examples in your opening
remarks
but I'd like you to give us a specific
definition of diversity in the context
of the University of North Carolina
and I'd also like you to give us a a
clear idea of exactly
what the educational benefits of
diversity at the University of North
Carolina
would be
so Clarence Thomas very good lawyer he
says look this word diversity is really
slippery so I need you to give me a
definition of what diversity actually
means because I can't quite nail it down
and then after that I don't want to hear
about the social benefits of diversity
the political benefits of diversity I
don't want to hear about the benefits to
the black students or the Asian students
or obviously doesn't benefit the Asians
very well or anything else
I want you to tell me
what educational purpose is served by
diversity now this should be a layup
if
the UNC and Harvard have any case at all
for their their unjust racial
discriminatory practices in college
admissions this should have been the
first answer that they figure out and
memorize it should be so easy right
but here's the answer
yes your honor so first we Define
diversity the way this court has in its
Court's precedence which means a broadly
diverse set of criteria that extends to
all different backgrounds and
perspectives and not solely limited to
race and there's a factual finding in
this record pet app 113 that there are
many different diversity factors that
are considered as a greater factor in
our admissions process than race on the
educational benefits question your honor
I don't think it's actually disputed
here that there are real and meaningful
educational benefits that come with
diversity of all kinds sfa's own expert
this is on ja 546 conceded and agreed
enthusiastically in fact on the stand
that a racially diverse and a diverse
diversity of all kinds leads to quote a
deeper and richer learning environment
leads to more creative thinking and
exchange of ideas and critically reduce
bias between people of different
backgrounds and not solely from racial
backgrounds
uh but you still haven't given me the
educational benefits
you love
love Clarence Thomas there just in that
really slow plotting it's he's almost
like the Norm Macdonald of the Court
which is that he's an extremely
intelligent man but he kind of plays
dumb sometimes and it's Scalia did this
to some degree as well
so he says okay it's a simple question
what's the educational benefit of
diversity
and the lawyer says well there's
actually a total consensus among all the
really smart fancy people that diversity
is really really good and they all say
that it's really really good and they've
said for years actually that diversity
is really really good and that's why
diversity is really really good for
education
and Clarence Thomas there it goes
um
maybe I'm a little slow maybe I'm a
little thick I don't know but uh
you didn't answer the question you're
telling me that other people agree with
you but you're not telling me why you're
not presenting any sort of evidence even
the definition of diversity he doesn't
really address he just says a lot of
jargon and gobbled ebook and says well
there's all different types of diversity
I think Clarence Thomas
I I hope he never retires from the court
if he does he's got to come straight to
daily wire so we can make a walsh-esque
movie what is diversity
there's what is a woman starring Walsh
what is diversity starring Clarence
Thomas the answers are going to be
completely nonsensical in both
this was really devastating I think to
the UNC and Harvard and pro-affirmative
action argument here on their most basic
question they don't have an answer what
good is diversity
in education for Education they don't
have an answer
because the answer is obvious
diversity in itself is not always or
even often a good thing why explain to
me why diversity
take the word however you want to take
it because it's hard to pin down like
Clarence Thomas says why is diversity a
good thing
is the on our money does it say out of
many
even many different things out of many
more out of many
far greater distinction and difference
and individualism no it says Unum out of
many one
we are not the diverse States of America
we are the United States of America
Unity is a strength
diversity is not a strength it's a
weakness
so
when when you bring in people of
different backgrounds or different
experiences or different what whatever
that can be all well and good but it it
has to it has to come with a Unity so if
we're going to have a country made up of
lots of different types of people we
need to all speak the same language we
have to broadly believe the same things
we have to be engaged in the same common
Endeavor we have to recognize the same
common good in a university you can
bring in people of any kinds of
background if you like but this is the
very point of the university the
university is supposed to bring you all
together for the single-minded pursuit
of truth that's why it's a university
it's not a DOT it's not a diversity it's
a university it's right there in the
very word
absolutely devastating to the case and
and so I think if the
if the UNC and Harvard team can't muster
better arguments than that
hard to see how affirmative action
survives 2023 really really good news to
look forward to speaking of attacks on
diversity
big news from Apple Apple has just
announced that the iPhone is going to be
getting USBC ports so right now it's got
that lightning Port but it's going to
change the port and they're changing it
they're really irritated they have to
change it they're changing it because
the European Union forced them to the
European Union passed a law that
requires all phones and tablets sold in
the EU to use USBC by 2024 and because
it's such a huge Market they can
basically Force Apple to give that to
everybody and I mentioned this story not
because I care about tech or apple or
anything like that but this is the kind
of story that's going to split people on
the right because you're going to have
the libertarian types
we're going to hate this and they're
going to say this is big government
sticking its nose in where it doesn't
belong and apple has a right to use
whatever charging ports it wants and
this is a terrible thing and a great
threat to freedom and then you're gonna
have the conservatives who say okay who
cares that's fine
people have the right in our political
Community to decide how we live and the
phone is now essential to how we live
specifically the iPhone and so we have a
right to say okay we're going to use
this charging port the charging port
itself doesn't really matter
but the broader issue of how we view
politics actually does and I think
from I don't know the year 2010 to 2015
that that more libertarian view really
dominated let the corporations do
whatever they want come on don't let the
government get in the way I mean and you
you heard kind of an undertone of that
really even for two or three decades now
I think that is changing and I think
conservatives are beginning to realize
the government is not always our enemy
and the corporations are not always our
friend
and and and sometimes it's actually a
little bit tricky to tell the difference
between where the public sector ends and
the private sector begins where the
government ends and the corporations
begin and we need to wield political
power where we can and and when we can
for justice does it matter with the
charging ports I don't really think so
but on bigger questions on the kind of
questions that the libs are trying to
call a true sign now on education on
Health Care on drugs on big Pharma on
all of that we must wield
our power totally fine totally fine with
that
speaking of government tyranny really
important new report just came out from
The Intercept haven't seen it going
around as much as it should read this
report from The Intercept truth cups
leaked documents outlined dhs's plans to
police disinformation
so what did we learn from this report
the report shows that basically big Tech
has been colluding with the government
to censor right-wingers and they've been
doing it not just in a kind of vague way
where you know maybe uh Zuckerberg and
some big lib in the government go out
and have a drink and they kind of come
to an agreement no they did this in a
very formal way Facebook and Twitter set
up special portals for the government to
rapidly request the takedown of content
so if I go out there and I start posting
some questions about the 2020 election
let's say or I go out there and I start
posting some questions about the
vaccines or posting questions about the
origin of the covet virus or anything
like that
the government could go in there and
rapidly request that that content come
down and we know that that content has
come down I mean we saw we saw it happen
during 2020. just with one story the New
York Post posts the hunter Biden laptop
story it instantly comes down you you
see big Tech almost uniformly not only
censor the story from being posted but
in many cases stop it even from being
sent through private messages when you
logged on to a lot of social media sites
in 2020 you couldn't even privately send
that story to your friends why did that
happen
we now have it because of these leaks in
this report FBI agent Laura demlo was in
communication with Facebook that led
specifically to the suppression of the
hunter Biden laptop story because the
FBI told Facebook that it was
disinformation
and then just this year she met with
with uh Twitter and DHS to stress quote
we need immediate infrastructure that is
accountable we find out now because of
emails and documents that have come out
that Vijaya Gaddy she was that that
Twitter apparatchik who censored Donald
Trump booted the duly elected sitting
president out of the Public Square that
Vijaya Gaddy met monthly
with the Department of Homeland Security
to discuss censorship plans one
Microsoft executive even texted the
Department of Homeland Security and said
platforms have got to get comfortable
with government
okay so this is not just oh there's one
bad actor oh there's a little bit of
corruption here the whole system is
extremely corrupt and it finally makes
sense now why the libs are losing their
freaking mind over Elon Musk taking over
Twitter first of all shouldn't they be
happy that Elon Musk is taking over
Twitter we're finally getting more
diversity big Tech is finally one
platform is owned by an African-American
they should be thrilled about this and
an immigrant for that matter gosh it
checks every box right Elon Musk is not
some Far right-wing conservative he
didn't he vote for Obama I mean isn't he
he certainly holds a lot of positions
that Obama would have held he's kind of
a I always thought he was kind of a
center-left guy is some kind of
right-wing positions but most
importantly most importantly
they can't totally control him
he does things that they apparently do
not like
I don't think that he is going to be
allowing the federal government to come
and run roughshod over our speech rights
he he took over Twitter on the The
Promise
that it will be much
more open to all speech and especially
to conservative speech and the libs
don't like that because the libs never
ever want you questioning the narrative
that's why they're so worried about this
right now they have a total lock on the
narrative you know I'm giving a speech
tonight at the University of Kentucky
I'm going to be giving it on conspiracy
theories because you know it's it's
one of the two worst things you can be
called in the country worst thing you
can be called as a racist because that
means you're just the absolute
embodiment of evil racism is just a
synonym for evil
and the second worst thing is a
conspiracy theorist because it means
you're the dumbest kookiest quack out
there
and so those combined are the two worst
things and yet
the strange thing with the conspiracy
theories is well at one just like racism
it's hard to figure out exactly what
that term means but two
plenty of conspiracy theories have been
proven true like this one like the
conspiracy theory that the government is
colluding with the the social media
platforms to censor the Public Square
into Buddha conservatives that's just a
that's a conspiracy fact okay that's a
conspiracy theorem all right we've
proven it
and it's true of so many other
conspiracy theories I mean we know that
the the federal government the
bureaucracy has been involved in
controlling the media for many decades
in this country you think about
something like operation Mongoose which
I'll talk about tonight well this is
just a continuation of that except with
far greater efficacy because here it's
so technologically advanced you can
actually just go in and say nope that
person's silenced Boop you're gone nope
that story nuked you can't even
privately talk about it
and so much more highly targeted this is
why
you have people in the popular culture
who are who you might not expect who are
questioning the narrative one of them is
Kyrie Irving I'm not uh not the biggest
basketball fan as you might know you
know not uh not the most athletic fella
out there Kyrie Irving I was just
watching his interview uh his press
conference and I expect the press to be
talking about basketball and stuff like
that and instead I find all the Press
wants to talk about is the fact that
Kyrie Irving posted
a generally innocuous
seemingly innocuous Alex Jones clip once
to his Instagram
okay while we're on the topic of
promotion
why did you decide to promote something
that Alex Jones said
that was a few weeks ago I do not stand
with Alex Jones
position narrative
court case that he had with Sandy Hook
or any of the kids that felt like they
had to relive trauma or parents that had
to relive trauma or to be dismissive to
all the lives that were lost during that
tragic event
my my post was a post from Alex Jones
that he did in the early 90s or late 90s
about secret societies in America of
occults and it's true so I wasn't
identifying with anything of being a
campaigning a campaignist for Alex Jones
or anything which is there to post and
it's funny
and it's actually hilarious because out
of all the things I posted that day that
was the modern post that everyone chose
to
chose to see just goes back to the way
our world is and works I'm not here to
complain about it I just exist
and to follow up on the promotion of the
movie in the book can you please stop
calling her a promotion
because that was the nice part of the
this reporter just keeps showing but why
do you like Alex Jones why are you
promoting Alex Jones why do you come on
stop you can't promote Alex you can't
talk about Alex Jones you can't why why
and Kyrie Irving is saying look I know
man I don't know about the Sandy Hook
thing or what I don't care I'm not I'm
not saying anything about that I posted
a clip from 30 Years Ago by the way
here's the clip the faction Common Sense
Arena and yes there have been corrupt
Empires yes they manipulate yes there
are secret societies yes there have been
oligarchies throughout history and yes
today in 2002 there is a tyrannical
organization calling itself the New
World Order pushing for
worldwide government a cashless Society
total and complete tyranny by
centralizing and socializing Health Care
the state becomes God basically when it
comes to your health and then by
releasing diseases and viruses and
plagues upon us we then basically get
shoved into their system where human
beings are absolutely worthless that's
just true
that's just that's just a fact I mean
what's he saying there have been
oligarchies in history
people sometimes conspire in small
groups to seize power and there is a a
popular phrase called the new world
order that that uh certain people are
advocating for today we would probably
call that more the great reset but it's
the same thing you just have very
prominent people using this phrase
saying we need a great reset we need a
new world order that's just a fact so
why
even by the way so Kyrie Irving right
he's very quick to say I don't you're
trying to talk to me about a Sandy Hook
shooting on I have nothing I'm not
saying anything about that I obviously I
I think that's bad that he said that I'm
okay bad Alex Jones but what's your pro
why can't I post this clip about how
political power is often different than
it appears to be
what no you're not allowed to post that
I mean it makes you wonder the fact that
they're punishing Alex Jones this way
but you've now got a court order that
he'd pay upwards of a billion dollars
for getting a story wrong on the air
yes he got the story very wrong yes it
was horrible but he said yes he's the
worst person in the world okay fine sure
I mean I mean let's let's just grant all
that a billion dollars for saying for
getting a story wrong on the air
followed by now the the demand for 2.75
trillion dollars it's just so bizarre
when you think that many other people in
our culture have said
way crazier things way way more harmful
things that have had much more of a
harmful effect in the real world I mean
just talk about what the kind of lies
and misinformation that went on during
covet from the libs who are now
demanding a truce and an amnesty and
pleading for it I mean those lies
resulted in much more actual real world
harm than anything that even Alex Jones
has said and sure he said totally wacky
okay sure fine but
in terms of real world harm it hasn't
been more harmful than what Anthony
fauci said hasn't been more harmful than
what Rachelle valenski said Joe Biden
said or any of these other people so why
do they go because
when when Kyrie Irving I haven't spoken
to him about this but when Kyrie Irving
sees
not the kind of multi-trillion dollar
requests billion dollar judgments
against someone for saying something
when when he's just being inundated at
his press conference by these questions
about this one random clip he posted
that was basically Anodyne in and of
itself
that is going to give him and other
people more reason to believe huh
maybe maybe there is a kind of oligarch
political power here I wasn't totally
convinced of it before but now
but now I wonder
conspiracy theories such as they are
grow
ing periods of a lack of trust in our
political institutions
and
that's not the end of the story
people lose trust in our institutions
because of corruption and conspiracy
that actually takes place we've got
we've got the evidence of it in black
and white
you know the corporate media agenda
means that the news is presented in a
biased way you know it I know it
everybody knows it thankfully there is a
way to get the most important news of
the day without their narrative that is
by listening to one of the top news
podcasts morning wire new episodes are
available every morning seven days a
week and they cover stories other media
Outlets won't touch every Sunday until
the midterm elections you can also tune
into election wire for in-depth coverage
candidate interviews and more it's the
most important midterm election in
recent history it's coming up soon
you'll want to be informed you will find
morning wire and election wire on Apple
podcast Spotify daily wire Plus or
wherever you listen to podcasts
speaking of the deep State attacking
conservatives
Lee zeldon is uh he's the Republican
candidate for governor in New York and
all of a sudden he's under investigation
for Super PAC violations
areas being reported by the hill
Lee's Eldon the Republican candidate for
Governor New York Senator investigation
by the State Board of Elections over
allegations that he coordinated with two
super Pacs supporting his campaign
what does this mean
according to our current
silly election laws
candidates can raise an unlimited amount
of money
that is people who support candidates
can donate an unlimited amount of money
to support that Canada but the election
laws for some stupid reason say you
can't donate the money directly to the
candidates campaign
you have to donate it to something
called a Super PAC which is a totally
separate group that according to the law
can have absolutely no coordination or
anything whatsoever with the campaign
now the Super PAC only exists
to support the candidate
or the some con men have exploited this
law to pretend they say I've got a Super
PAC I've got the new the new Super PAC
to support Donald Trump and they've
really never talked to Donald Trump and
they really have never coordinated with
Donald Trump and they really have no
intention of giving any money to help
Donald Trump they just use it to make
money for themselves and you saw a lot
of these crop up since this stupid Super
PAC
aspect of the law has gone into effect
but when it works perfectly the idea is
yes you've got two entities the campaign
pack and the Super PAC both of which are
designed to get this candidate elected
but they're not allowed to coordinate
with each other one little bit
so
that's the background did Lee zeldin
coordinate with his Super PAC I don't
know like maybe I don't even what does
that even mean was he at an event that
his Super PAC was also at
well that's true of every candidate of
both parties in the country that that
sort of has to happen because that's
where the that's where the action is
right that's where the that's what the
money is for
now is it that Lee zeldon or one of his
staff members uh coordinated on a TV
commercial or a mailer or I don't know I
don't know I don't really care I don't I
know the Democrats do this sort of thing
all the time and I know that New York is
one of the most corrupt states in the
country when it comes to the government
it's New York Illinois is really bad
about that California is not so hot
itself but New York in particular is
where Albany is really really corrupt
and so why are they doing this
now they're doing this of course because
Lee's Elgin is not supposed to be
leading in this race because New York's
a Democrat State and Kathy hokel is
supposed to glide into re-election
and that's that and the fact that the
people are now seem to be supporting Lee
zeldin that's a big problem
and so the the state the bureaucracy the
corrupt powers that be
going to have to come in and kind of
tilt that back for the Democrats would
you call that a conspiracy
if you talk about that would you call it
a conspiracy theory I guess so it's a
theory about a conspiracy but there's
some evidence for it
and especially in light of everything
else that we're learning now about how
the government is putting its thumb its
boot on the scales for the Democrats the
theory seems to have a fair bit of
credibility speaking of people breaking
the law there's an update to the Paul
Pelosi story
you know Paul Pelosi Nancy Pelosi's
husband
ends up in an altercation with this
Berkeley nudist
who was in the green party and then but
now he's being portrayed as a right-wing
mag a republican but if you look at the
house he was staying at it's got rainbow
flags and BLM signs and they'll and he's
in the Pelosi house at 2AM how did he
get there I don't it seems kind of weird
I mean listen people have broken into
Buckingham Palace before so I'm not
saying it's impossible but wouldn't you
expect the speaker of the house and the
second person in the line of succession
of the president have some home security
surely she has cameras all over it the
whole thing is just really
weird
then on the dispatch tape Paul the the
person relaying this dispatch says that
Paul Pelosi says he doesn't know the guy
but he names him he calls him David and
he says that he's a friend and so that
doesn't add up anyway the whole story is
really weird and now it's gotten even
stranger
because the guy who attacked Pelosi
David depape
apparently is an illegal alien
and I
I'm not gonna laugh I'm not gonna don't
Michael don't laugh I'm very happy that
Paul Pelosi is going to make a full
recovery
it's good even if he's married to the
Wicked Witch of the West he's a fellow
human being I don't want to laugh about
anything but
is an illegal alien
that's
he's
the Republicans have spent decades
the conservatives at least have tried to
stop the illegal alien problem liberals
like Nancy Pelosi encourage illegal
immigration they say it's wonderful
illegal immigration diversity it's our
strength they've got it and then
it's
ironic no it's not even ironic it's just
it actually is completely expected by
people who look at this political
situation and and the liberals do it too
the Liberals know that illegal
immigration is really bad and dangerous
for a lot of people they just think
they're protected this is why they threw
such a hissy fit when DeSantis sent the
plainloads of illegals up to Martha's
Vineyard
they said this is a humanitarian crisis
this is awful it's a drain on our
resources it's dangerous we've got to
they shipped them off to a military base
within 48 Hours okay
why it's not because they suddenly
realize the reality of illegal
immigration they've always known that
it's dangerous and bad for the
communities that have to deal with it
they just said okay it's just for those
poor people on the southern border it's
for those Texans and those arizonans
it's not for us in Martha's Vineyard
it's not for us the Pelosi's
Pelosi is dealing with it now
two speaking of uh crazy people
there was another attack
on a painting
there have been all of these attacks I
actually was in London there was this
attack on a van Gogh painting where
these lib environmentalist types threw a
bunch of soup on it and then super glued
themselves to the wall and then a day or
two later I got to see the painting
there I brought a spoon there was no
soup left they cleaned it up which I
guess was good
well there there have been more and more
attacks and now another one this Maniac
is super glowing his head to a painting
take a listen
the painting that he's super gluing his
head to is a girl with the Pearl Earring
by Vermeer I mean this is a very very
famous very important painting
[Music]
do you feel outraged
well you should be more outraged about
the destruction of our Earth that's the
point that's the thesis of this stupid
protest is you're saying you're out
right and this happened at the Hague by
the way
they're saying you're outraged that
we're attacking this work of art on a
canvas but but you're all attacking the
the great work of art that is the the
environment with your pollution and your
Plastics and all and they they're just
going to keep this up
it's it's it reminds me of that scene in
The Jerk with Steve Martin where the guy
is sniping and trying to kill Steve
Martin and he's at a gas station he
keeps hitting all the cans of oil so
this guy really hates these cans
so these environmentalists really hate
these paintings and they just keep
they're gonna eventually they're gonna
destroy one of them and it's going to be
very very annoying
but that's that's the argument and they
are getting the attention that they so
desperately crave
and they are they are shedding a light
on environmentalism
which could be a good thing actually
because the more we look into these
radical environmentalists
the clearer it becomes
they're not helping the natural
environment
there was a study it's been it's being
promoted by Greenpeace
which is the Environmental non-profit
uh though I think it's actually kind of
self-underminding study from Greenpeace
turns out that plastic recycling is
totally fake it's so fake
we so the study shows of the 51 million
tons of plastic waste the U.S households
generated in 2021 just 2.4 million tons
just five percent of that was recycled
and it's not because
the people don't put it in the little
blue bin or I mean I generally don't but
but some people people are very
meticulous generally got to put this
bottle in the blue bin or else I'm
committing a sin against mother Gaia and
Mother Earth and so blah blah whatever
but part of the reason is just there are
so many different types of plastic the
plants are not very efficient at
processing all of them and so only five
percent of it ever gets recycled it's
just fake you're you're you're
performing a kind of ritual in the
religion of Mother Earth but you're not
really doing very much to help the
natural environment so it's obviously
totally fake and stupid but
there there is a kind of conservative
Insight here and I think conservatives
are going to have to
we're going to have to come to terms
with the natural environment because
for the past several decades where we've
just had this this kind of
Ein Rand uh you know sort of political
view where everything's just about money
and you know Wolf of Wall Street greed
is good like that that kind 1980s kind
of political views we're coming out of
that hangover right now and the the
ethos of that political view was who
cares about the environment whatever I'm
just going to throw these little uh you
know soda can holders into the into the
ocean see how many bottlenose dolphins I
can NAB and I'm just going to set a
bunch of tires on fire and I'm just
gonna whatever who cares you know and
that is not it's it's funny and it's
reactionary and it's reacting to these
lunatics and nuts who are gluing their
heads to you know Vermeer paintings but
it's not actually all that conservative
it's not it's not conservative to trash
our surroundings that's what hippies do
that's what Libs do they trash their
surroundings and they make it look like
the Woodstock campsite okay that's not
what conservatives do we like beautiful
things and but the key here
toward a conservative environmentalism
or conservationism or don't forget Teddy
Roosevelt is one of the first
conservationists
the key to it is the focus
is it about Mother Earth and Gaia and
the Delta smelt and the rocks and the
whatever or is it about human beings
the libs basically think that we are the
pollution they think that we are the
virus and we need to just get rid of
humans and stop building things and stop
doing things and stop living and then
that'll be really good because then we
can serve the Delta smelt
the conservative view of it is
yeah we want to take care of the natural
environment and we don't want to kill
off all the species and we want the air
to be nice for us because we are
stewards of the creation and we want to
flourish it is it is not the end it's
not that we need to orient our industry
and our economy and our way of life
towards serving the end of the rocks and
the trees or whatever it's hugging the
trees and crying when they cut one down
we it's it's that we need to govern and
Steward our environment
for our society so that we have a good
flourishing society and so that we can
go out and you know go shooting those
birds and chopping down those trees in
in Beauty and peace
so we've got the love don't judge
challenge today
it's very spooky It's a Spooky post
Halloween love don't judge challenge uh
the rest of the show is continuing now
you do not want to miss this if you are
not a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]